well we're gonna get started so hi and
welcome to our webcast MBA student
insights LGBT at the GSB my name is
Marco and I'm a second year MBA student
here at the GSB and we'll be talking
about the LGBT student experience here
on campus and try to answer as many
questions as we can to submit a question
to us about what it's like to be a
student here just click the chat button
at the top of your screen enter your
question and click send to all panelists
so click the chat button at the top and
do your question and enter send to all
panelists we're not gonna be talking
about the admissions process the
application or financial aid but there
are staff from the MBA admissions office
that are gonna answer those types of
questions directly in the chat box
itself all right so first things first
we're gonna start off with some intros
I have Wynn and Marcela here why don't
you start by telling us a bit about
where you're from what you did before
coming to the GSB and what your goals
are after graduation also I guess I'll
kick us off my name is Wynn Chesson I'm
so excited to be on this panel I grew up
in Chapel Hill North Carolina so I came
out I went to the school of the
University of North Carolina at Chapel
Hill for undergrad stayed women's
studies gender studies and sexuality
studies and then I went to work in New
York City for an LGBT rights nonprofit
called immigration equality so all of my
professional experience prior to the GSP
was actually focused on championing LGBT
equality especially for immigrant
communities in the United States and I'm
a career switcher so I'm not exactly
sure what's next for me but I'm really
excited to be at the GSB to have so many
amazing new opportunities and so ask me
in a year right now hello everyone also
very excited to be here my name is
Marcela I am from Mexico I went to
Monterrey Tech where I studied
Industrial Engineering
then had a more traditional background
doing management consulting for two
years but I'm now after the GSB going to
go work at the Nature Conservancy which
is an environmental nonprofit and I'm
very excited about that also glad to be
here today
perfect thanks Ursula and so as for
myself like I said my name is Marco Chan
I'm a second year here at the GSB but
coincidentally just like when I'm a dual
degree student in public administration
at the Kennedy School as well in terms
of before school I studied romance
studies are actually I'm from Canada so
you have NAFTA up here and I also live
for a while in Macao in terms of
educational background I studied romance
studies at Harvard and then worked at
Bain and Bain & Company and consulting
for a couple of years and was at the
World Bank for a bit in international
development and then long-term I'm
considering either LGBT advocacy
full-time or I'm also really interested
in Canadian politics and policy so
awesome very dissimilar things all right
well so with that why don't we just get
started with some questions that the
audience is submitted so how do we start
with the first one
what's what is the LGBT community like
at the GSB so I should start by saying I
love the GSB and one of the most
important communities for me since I've
gotten here has been GSB pride and
that's kind of like the all-inclusive
MBA one and be a 2 and a 3 mm tax yeah
one year students PhD students and I
think it's because they host a retreat
kind of very soon after you get onto
campus so as you're kind of establishing
yourself and trying to make friends with
section mates it's kind of nice to break
away from that from a minute and get to
meet not just people of your year
outside of your section but also get to
me like start friendships that are NBA
2's or you know I came at both of you at
that retreat and that was just really
meaningful so that's kind of how it
started for me yeah I really wanted to
do it win go first
as you mentioned I'm an MBA 3 the
program is usually two years as I'm sure
you know but I'm joined the great
candidate with the school of Earth
energy and environmental studies so AI
per so I wanted to provide the historic
perspective and it's been really
exciting to see how the GFP fried
community has changed there were fewer
of us when I started and it was more in
a way a more homogeneous community and
I'm really excited to see now like I
hope you'll talk about prom where you
got to wear dragon I just feel like the
conversations and the experience here
being so much more inclusive and
stronger and again coming back to the
fact that I'm an MBA 3 it's really
exciting to like make friends with the
first years even now after my friends
graduate and I'm with the second years
and I'm giv pride has really been at the
core of that yeah i'm i think as for my
thoughts on what the LGBT community's
been like here i'll offer two things i
think the first is that for me partly
because my social and professional
interest is in the LGBT community it
always feels like home base so it's nice
that we have a group where it's big
enough that to your points there's quite
a bit of diversity in our group in terms
of work background where people grew up
ideologies even there's enough of that
but it's also a tight knit enough group
where I feel like I really do know every
single person to one degree or another
um so it's nice to have you know we get
together every Thursday for drinks in
different people's houses like we have
events all the time we'll go together to
different pan Stanford or local San
Francisco LGBT events so it's nice to
have that community and then I think the
second thing I'll share is that again to
what Marcel has said I think frankly I
was kind of surprised by how
international our LGBT experience is we
have people from China India Saudi
Arabia Canada Mexico Brazil so I think
it's really enriched discussions that
we've had particularly with allies
around what it means for us to think
about inclusion
and diversity in our own personal lives
but also in the workplace to all these
different places that people are gonna
people from the GSB will ultimately end
up back at so that's a piece I'll share
around that and the second question that
we have is how did you know it was the
right time for you to get an MBA why
wasn't it five years ago why wasn't it
two years later I thought again being in
management consulting I thought that I
was like under a deadline to apply
before my two years were up it turned
out maybe that wasn't quite what I
thought it was but I just thought I had
to do it at that point
the right time is probably when you feel
it's the right time I'm super glad I got
to do it then because the GSB has really
allowed me to leverage what I had
learned in consulting but really
transition to a career that's very
meaningful to me so in a way I want to
say like this and are the better but
whenever he's right whenever he's right
for you for me it was um if you if you
kind of rewind it back 7 years and asked
me would I be getting an MBA I think I
might answer would have been absolutely
no but the more I worked in the LGBT
rights world the more value I saw as
kind of the organization I was working
for partnered more North fortune 500
companies and when I kind of decided to
come back to school was after an
enormous victory for our community and I
think you know the United States Supreme
Court issued the Windsor decision and
and one of the three things in my
Gration equality was working on was
being able to apply for a green card for
your same-sex husband or wife and so
once we won that key victory obviously
there's a lot more to do but it was this
turning-point moment where I got to
reassess and kind of figure out what do
I want to do next so for me it was kind
of marked by that milestone and I always
loved school so the idea of doing
something that could both help me gain
new skills new knowledge at a moment of
uncertainty so kind of seemed like too
good to be true and I remember I visited
Stanford and I had this
feeling like I just stepped onto the gsv
campus I don't know if you all felt this
but I I loved it immediate like
everything was beautiful but there was
there's this town square and people are
waving across yeah I know the quad and
it was just it seemed really like a cozy
community and so I think that that also
kind of accelerated the okay this is
where I want to be now nice
I'll mines brief basically diddle
Marcella yeah I'll say in particular it
just felt like the right time after a
couple of years of my previous work to
just do some soul-searching about about
future directions and my values so keep
it there
the third question that we have is I
like this one so how did you know the
GSB was the right school for you and we
touched on that a little bit there's a
magic moment that um I I mean I met
people when I was considering applying
to the MBA program and I met people who
had been to different schools I just
found myself being more attracted to the
the way that GSB rice expressed
themselves and I remember in one of my
Eyes's I wrote that what I like about
Stanford is that people talked about
dreams and not just goals so he just
there was like this aura of excitement
and following your passion and trying to
do something good for it for the world
and not used yourself and that just yeah
I was very attracted to that yeah I
think I mean I do when I visited I it
was just a feeling that I had I I think
that that was maybe a piece of it but I
couldn't quite identify it for me it
it's it sounds funny but it was actually
going to one of the presentations that
the GSB admissions officers does around
the cities so I was working in Atlanta
at the time and I went to the
presentation there and what struck me
about what she said and what the alumni
who came into the presentation were like
was that this is a place where we think
about where people are empowered to
think about I think how success is
different from meaning and that by by
pursuing meaning
at some point you'll find success at
some point you'll be able to sustain
yourself and your material needs and so
worry about your passion worry about
your spirit and worry about your like
hone in on those values and that's
what's important and I think getting the
option of my soul-searching present it
to me that way was just so compelling I
was like I don't I'm kind of done with
with achieving for achieving I'm done
with ticking boxes I really do want to
go to this place where those peers the
structure the the institutions the
courses are gonna push me to do what is
truly important and meaningful so once I
saw that butterfly cocoon slide on the
presentations like alright more
questions this is fun
how how receptive are employers to LGBT
students do they host events are their
career panels that are LGBT oriented so
I as a career switch I so the my old job
in LGBT rights like diversity in that
context was the street people that
worked for us but I was really I feel
like as I'm pivoting to much more
traditional things at least for the
summer I feel like it was an incredible
advantage to have the LGBT targeted
networking like all of the consulting
firms a lot of the banks did targeted
dinners or receptions on campus or in
nearby for specifically for LGBT
students so I feel like kind of as a way
to get a little to have like an internal
champion at any of the companies
especially if you're going to a more
traditional pathway for the summer yeah
I felt like it was a total advantage I
guess we both worked in industry before
from the other side of that I can tell
it really helps when you attend these
events and the access that you get to
people who are working there and
partners and so on so it's really it can
really make a difference for going into
traditional careers and even just
reaching out alums that if you know the
company that you're that you're
interested in for this summer you have
like one additional filter that you
can try on and I found that I mean GSB
alumni have been so responsive but the
LGBT alumni have like gone above and
beyond every time they like a hundred
percent that's yeah that's that's a
great point and absolutely absolutely
true as I was doing this job search I
completely relied on LGBT alumni or
contact us all and so great point yeah I
think I'll just add that reaching out
MBA is another great resource for folks
that are kind of at this life stage and
looking at different business paths so
it's an organization that serves MBAs
and prospective MBAs who are LGBTQ
identified so there's a conference every
year we went it was tons of fun I think
it's a Dallas this year it's also a
great chance for us to connect with both
LGBT employers and other LGBT MBAs and
prospective MBAs from across the country
well North America so alright well do
the next question then do do any of the
classes address LGBT issues I jump into
this one because I am actually working
on an extension that came out of LGBT
content in a class so I took a class
here on it was called advanced topics in
philanthropy and as a part of that
I wasn't presented with a particular
case or something that was LGBT focused
but as with most classes here I had a
lot of latitude in deciding what my
assignments we're going to be on and how
I was gonna focus my own lens and my own
experience at the class so I ended up
writing a longer paper about LGBTQ
philanthropy which then the professor
went and said this is super interesting
it's very contemporary and I'd like to
actually extend this and turn into
teaching materials so I think the class
at some future point will actually have
that as something to teach with but
that's one way that I infuse by myself
LGBT content in class and professors are
as long as you're working with something
you're excited about professors are
super happy to let you do what you want
yeah I'm not aware of any like
explicitly LGBTQ classes at the GSB but
I know that you can take classes
anywhere at the University and that some
there are LGBT themed
classes outside of the GSB that we're
allowed to take not aware of any oh
there is right I'm in the class right
now
so I I am in another course right now
called reputation management and
actually as a part of that very recently
we've had two back-to-back LGBT speakers
come in oh wow
so one was Raymond Braun who's an it was
a Stanford undergrad graduate who came
in and talked about his online activism
on LGBT rights with YouTube and then the
second speaker who came in and talked to
us about and of how you manage your
reputation at the frontier of a movement
she was a GSB alum who played a huge
role in the repeal of Don't Ask Don't
Tell and so she actually walked us
through that experience and related it
back to the class so I actually have had
some LGBT specific curriculum and then
the next question so how does being an
LGBT student at the GSB relate to your
next career move and another way of
putting it how important is it to be
openly LGBT and being in an organization
that's gonna support that part of your
identity yeah that's that's really a
good one I think for the first part as
we said for traditional careers there
will be events and you can always reach
out to alumni but in terms of like how
how this kind of how it's important to
being an organization that will support
it I think just personally I mean I
couldn't bear any longer to work at an
organization where I had to be in the
closet it's just there's so much energy
that you have to pour into hiding things
and making things up and it deters your
the type of relationships that you've
had so again I didn't go into these jobs
through like an LGBT channel but I
definitely made sure that I'm honest and
open from the beginning about my sexual
orientation and my identity and I think
in the end that's a little bit of a
personal decision for each one a little
bit hopefully a decision to like try to
be a little bit activist and help
next person but yeah I mean there's so
much research saying that you have to be
yourself in order to you have to be
authentic and that's also something that
the GSB places a lot of emphasis on just
authenticity and how that helps build
your leadership style and and bring
others to support you so yeah that's
that's my take anything you want to add
to that um I mean I really agree with
authenticity piece for me it would be a
deal-breaker if I thought that the
employer didn't support LGBT rhymey knit
they could even I almost would say that
for me they'd have to have a hundred on
the HRC and exit like measures how well
companies do but for me I did kind of
I'm going to go in Saks this summer and
I I recruited through the traditional
channels but I feel like part of what
was successful there was I I kind of
also used the LGBT Network get the
inside scoop of like I see the HRC score
but what's it really like
and then also knowing about how they had
partnered unlike the LGBT stuff I'd done
before school really gave me the
confidence to believe and the score that
they had but I just can't imagine for me
being able to do it because all of my
relevant experience is really good yeah
so I'm kind of automatically outed based
on what I do and there's I think that
there are companies where that would not
be that helpful or like regions of the
world where I might it might be much
harder for me to work but I'm for me I'm
willing to make that sacrifice and I
even thought that what you just said
that like you wouldn't even consider
working at a place that wasn't accepting
of your identity like that's a great
privilege
yeah and coming from a country that's
like a little bit more conservative in
some places around that yeah I just it
strikes me as something that's like
really a privilege and impart something
that kind of come out of his experience
yeah and in fact we had we had an event
with allies yesterday where we were was
basically a workshop where we had
dialogue between LGBTQ students and
allies at the GSB
talking about what if your experience
has been like on the alle side and on
the LGBTQ side in the workplace in
particular and one ally mentioned and
her struggle around
she worked in a very conservative and
traditional industry where someone who
was LGBTQ identified really stood out by
by his or her here actions and so she
struggled to say like what what is my
place in that and so that for me really
underscored different people are gonna
are gonna have different priorities and
trade-offs and where they are in their
own coming-out journey so I I don't want
to minimize that either that's something
that yeah like I think we've talked
about but I want to really make sure it
comes through in the conversation that
it is very individual and contextual and
it's something that we I mean we've
talked a lot about just kind of casually
over drinks like Marco mentions
oftentimes on Thursdays a lot of the
LGBT students will get together and and
there's a there's a couple of our
classmates that like want to work in the
Middle East or you know that are going
back to home countries where it's not
quite as safe to be openly LGBT and how
do you navigate that like how do we
support one another you know talking
about should I come out to my supervisor
or like you know my supervisor super
however that works and so it's it's a
tricky question but it's one that I
think that people are really actively
100 percent so thinking about the next
question how how big is the LGBT
community at the GSB how big is it and
on the campus at large and what kind of
what kind of support or involvement or
interaction does the rest of our class
have with the LGBT community here again
I'll provide a it's it's another part of
like what's been so amazing I think I've
seen it like double from my class to
your class and then I don't know how it
was but like your class seems even
larger but yeah so there there's a good
group as you said I don't know I don't
know the exact numbers okay so I it's a
little it's a little tricky because
obviously it's something
that is self-identified people
self-identify her don't in different
context but what we did report out and
is available through reaching out is
that I think we're about five percent of
most of the classes which I think if I
remember the list was actually yeah
pretty high up in terms and then I'm
glad there's also question about the
campus at large because I've enjoyed
grad Q so much grad Q is the LGBT
Student Association for all graduate
schools so that's that includes some for
law school med school and like all the
other PhD and advanced degrees programs
and I've met so many interesting people
there I feel sometimes like my fellow
geocirrus even get this a great
opportunity to like meet so diverse so
many diverse people like social
psychology department law students like
everything I just really appreciate that
yeah that's true and then actually
constantly tomorrow night we are having
every once in a while all the LGBT folk
in the area take over a straight bar in
Palo Alto so that's actually tomorrow
night and yeah so it's a pretty sizable
community at at the GSB throughout
Stanford and in the immediate South Bay
Peninsula area and then of course I used
to live in San Francisco myself so I go
up to the city fairly often to see
friends that are there and so there's
obviously that community as well and
then to the second part of that question
and what kind of support or involvement
does the rest of the class have with us
I think we've we've alluded to this a
little bit with some of the ally events
but anything else you'd want to add to
that I would just say for me it was so
striking to how different it was to step
back into a university environment and
have had so much change like from when I
came out to when I went to university
where I think it was a much more kind of
hostile Experion there was supportive
pockets but I don't know that it was as
welcoming as I felt welcomed here and I
think about like every so every once a
week there are two people from your
class it will give what's called a talk
and they tell a lot of their life story
and you know obviously every so often
one of those people is LGBTQ and and I
feel like the conversations that get
sparked through that institution of talk
which is one of my favorite things about
Stanford have been really moving for me
and then also just the way that I think
about like the support that I have just
for my section and how they've welcomed
in my boyfriend so like we call all of
our partners SOS here and I feel like
he's been welcomed in so warmly by all
all students but I think that really
says a lot that like you know he there
are people there straight people in
particular like reach out to him before
they reach out to me and I love that
just because I feel like no it's kind of
like a sign of how things are really
changing and that feels really different
from when I was in undergraduate yeah I
think I'll just add that you know it's
not the GSB is really diverse right and
we mean that in all kinds of ways so I
don't want to paint over the fact that
there are people here with different
political points of view with different
ideological leanings but I think one
thing that's been super positive about
about the GSB is that kind of like
authenticity and the really I think
inquisitive culture that we have because
I have had lots of hearts heart to
hearts and and relationships with our
conversations with people where we have
disagreed right so I think the best
example would be a classmate of mine and
a friend posted something on Facebook
following the Supreme Court announcement
of same-sex marriage in the United
States where he disagreed and we ended
up having a very frank two-hour lunch
about what that meant how that landed on
me how his statement made me feel and we
we walked away actually finding more
more common ground than I expected and
we're still we're still close friends
and I still play with his kids so I I
appreciate those kinds of exchanges
because I recognize that the
disagreements and and the shifting
political winds will always be in some
way a part of our future
so I appreciate having the community
here to have that really open
candid dialogue anything so moving on to
the next question is GSB pride purely
social or do we take on advocacy work or
do other activities for the this video
session started because we were thinking
about there's a lot of things that a a
pride group could do like we could do
education around topics around hb2 and
like what that means for business or you
know panels about for straight allies we
could do networking stuff for helping
each other get jobs we could do social
stuff which we do a lot of and then
another thing I think we do a lot of is
if you think of people something for
some of our classmates this is the first
time where it's really been safe for
people to come out and so thinking back
to like when I came out how important
having a supportive community but also
like other support resources I think
that's one thing that pride does it's
not exactly social but providing all
kinds of support for coming out and like
what does that mean for the workplace
what does that mean in your social life
with your family yeah and then also like
advocacy around events like hv2 which we
haven't done as much on yeah and then I
I would kind of call but all the events
you're doing with allies kind of
advocacy slash education and another one
of the things I'm really excited to see
in recent years like the way you do that
it used to be more of a social club it's
evolved and I've seen it every year and
with other clubs always kind of evolving
to the needs and what people are excited
about yeah yeah I'd say it's fairly
dependent on the group of people back
that want to take action I think with
most clubs here they're they're fairly
open you'll find that all the clubs of
ten leaders because everyone wants to be
a leader but I think that works out in a
way where you share work and people
really take their own personal
initiative and so I think you know for
example when our year took over the
leadership it was we asked the people
that were there here and in coming you
know if five years from now when you
graduate why what will have pride have
done
for it to be memorable in your
experience and then we execute it off
that and much of that with social much
of that was in support some of it was
educational oh they'll change a bit year
to year I think what for me has been
really important as like been an
emphasis on building a community
whatever that means and so I feel really
connected to the LGBT people I think
particularly in my year but really at
the G Sol so in your third year
all right well time it's about really
does fly I think we're almost at a time
but before we go
when Marcella any final words of advice
for folks that are thinking about
applying to the Stanford MBA especially
if they're part of the LGBT community
I'll just shoot a couple out there reach
out to co-workers if you have if you
know someone who's LGBT and has attended
business school they can be great
sources of wisdom more generally just
really take some time to enjoy the
process of writing your essay I think
part of the decision to come here was
that I had to think so hard about it but
at the end I really felt like I know
myself better so it can be hard but
really enjoy talk to other people about
it take the opportunity to get your get
to know yourself better and yeah I hope
you enjoy it thanks for cela when yeah I
I really agree with that I think one
thing I want to flag and I know we're
not to talk about financial aid but
there are specific LGBT scholarships
that are like not necessarily specific
to Stanford but knowing about the point
foundation for me was really helpful and
then there also is LGBT specific yeah
money at Stanford so if you're able to
be out I think that that's I just wish
that that have been flagged for me and
the second thing is is I love talking to
potential applicants about like what
you're thinking about so kind of
following on your advice but if there's
someone that you can reach out to and
ask you know a little bit to get even
more of a peek into their experience and
to follow up with more questions I think
that I definitely recommend doing any
candidate to have those conversations as
you're going through that
process yeah I think my quick tidbit is
just to be authentic to your identity
for me like I said my professional
interest is in the LGBTQ community and
so of course that's gonna show up at
length in my application of course
that's gonna show up in my essays but
may or may not be the case for you
depending on how you want to live and
express that identity and their values
so put down what put down what makes
sense for you there isn't a magic
formula with your identity nor with
anything else in the application I
really think it is very holistic so on
that note well thank you both of you for
joining us and also everyone in the
audience for participating I think we're
all here because we love the school and
we love our community and we'd be super
excited to see some of y'all apply and
then ultimately come here you can learn
more about the MBA program on the GSB
website so the application for the class
starting in the fall of 2017 is going to
be available in June so its 2017
starting then application will be
available in June and if you have
questions about the MBA program you can
continue to submit them in the chat box
and there will be staff from the MBA
admissions office that are going to
answer them for about the next 15
minutes but that's it for us so thanks
again and have a great day thanks for
joining you